Lisbon is located on the river Tagus not
directly on the coast nevertheless the
ocean has long played an important role
in the city's history
Portugal's seafaring past is reflected
in Lisbon's architecture and the city's
proximity to the sea mirrored in its
cuisine the locals eat fish or seafood
almost every day a great place to sample
them is the fábrica de Santiago
restaurant where Carlos Robalo is head
chef you have so many traditions since
the sound to the north of Portugal there
are different regions for instance the
north with most of them it's knit and
the South eats fish so it's completely
different
you'll find a huge variety of fish and
seafood in the mercado de ba de one of
Lisbon's most famous indoor markets
numerous chefs come here to shop and get
some inspiration including Carlos
Cavalli I like that's the things that's
the products I like that's to the fish
to smell the fish to see that the color
of the fruits it's more easy sometimes
more easy for us or for me to pick up
the phone and ask me to a supplier but
know normally I'm going to the market
every day and choose everything
Venis clams can be found in coastal
waters the world over gaku show below
prepares them in a special dish named
after the 19th century Portuguese poet
hi mundo Antonio do booyah
who was also renowned for his recipes
first the clams were rinsed and then
placed in salted water they should have
opened after 30 minutes the other
ingredients are cilantro garlic salt
lemon olive oil and the knob of butter
the simple plate is very delicious it's
one of the most traditional in Portugal
I think everybody likes that chop the
cilantro and press the garlic heat the
oil and the garlic and add the Venus
clamps to simmer for a few minutes
add white wine and butter then add
cilantro and finally the lemon juice one
of Portugal's most famous appetizers is
ready to serve but this can also be
served as a main course with a marinated
pork loin
you're gonna give another structure to
the plate its interest
it's different for the customer it's
funny to mix together fry the pork loin
in olive oil and garlic add potatoes and
finally the army joyas the Venus clams a
tasty and filling main course
enjoy enjoy very much the Portuguese
people like very much lead so we mix the
meat of the wound wine and a good
company and all together give us a very
present stay on moment you know and the
perfect accompaniment to a perfect meal
of Venus clamps is a dry white wine and
lots of time to enjoy
you